اضراب شامل شل مختلف في مناحي الحياه في
الاراضي الفلسطينيه رافقته مسيره احتجاج
على احتجاز اسرائيل جثمان الاسير ناصر ابو
حميد الذي قضى داخل السجون الاسرائيليه
بعد معاناته مع مرض السرطان اهمال الطبي
هو تلكؤ في التشخيص وهذا بالمناسبه يحدث
مع كل الاسره ثم بعد ذلك اجريت له عمليه
جراحيه
وتعرض لخطا طبي لدخول طبيب يعني غير مختص
في العمليه يعني كانت تدخله
بان دخل ناصر في حاله غيبوبه اللي حوالي
اسبوعين نتيجه ايضا همم اهمال طبي
ناصر البالغ من العمر 50 عاما ام ضمنها 30
سنه في السجون الاسرائيليه اخرها منذ
العام 2002 اضافه الى اشقاء اربعه يقضون
احكاما مؤبده اسرائيل لم تستجب للمطالب
الفلسطينيه والعربيه والدوليه من اجل
تسليم جثمانه الى عائله
كل ما نريده ان نشيع ناصر كما يليق وكما
يجب وان ندفنه الى جانب اخي الشهيد عبد
المنعم هذا قوه مطلبنا
نحن اتصلنا مع اشقاء عرب مؤثرين سواء كان
على الجانب الاسرائيلي والتصلنا ايضا
بالجهات الامريكيه وبالاداره الامريكيه
للتدخل مباشره لتسليم جثمانه لا يعقل
اطلاقا شخص تعرض الى الاهمال الطبي هناك
اربع اخوان له اسره ما زالوا في سجون
الاحتلال يعني اقل ما يمكن بالحد الادنى
من التكريم ان يسلم الى والدته والى اخوته
اكثر من اربعه الاف فلسطينيه معتقلون في
السجون الاسرائيليه بينهما العشرات يعانون
من امراض مزمنه قد يواجهون نفس المصير
الذي لقيه ناصر
اسيرا فلسطيني
وما تزال اسرائيل تحتزجه
اليه من اليوم ناصر ابو حميد لتبقى
المطالبات الفلسطينيه بتحرير جثامين
الاسرى متواصله
على مختلف المستويات
من امامي مخيم الامعري قرب رام الله خالد
القاسم العربيه